yeah i think a lot of um people who have
done this happen in connecticut
understand how
unfair this is basically because these
biological males
were feeding us females by significant
margins in these races and it was
happening
at every every single race that we raced
against
we were losing and it was a big
difference
i'm dave rubin and we're going to be
doing something a bit different today
let me give you a little back story here
on may 22nd of this year usa today put
out an
op-ed from collegiate track star chelsea
mitchell
about her experiences competing against
transgender
athletes however on may 25th just three
days later the publication
changed the word male to transgender
throughout her piece without warning and
called her out for using
quote hurtful language in an editor's
note the outlet explained that the op-ed
was
updated to quote reflect usa today's
standards and style guidelines
we regret that hurtful language was used
today i'm speaking with the author of
that op-ed and her lawyer
please welcome one of the fastest girls
in connecticut track star chelsea
mitchell
and her lawyer who is the general
counsel at the alliance defending
freedom
kristin wagoner ladies welcome to the
reuben report
thank you thank you all right so i'm
glad to have both of you
uh kristen i reached out to you
originally when i saw this
story on twitter because it just so fits
so many of the things
that i've been talking about on this
show
uh chelsea i'll i'll start with you
since you wrote the original piece
um well i guess first just tell me how
you got into track and and and you enjoy
running right like that's really what
this is all about you want to compete
against girls
and running yeah i was an african
my entire life when i got to high school
i started running track
um and i kind of quickly realized that i
was really good at it and
unfortunately my experience in high
school was
um you know not the best because i had
to race again
biological males my entire high school i
lost a lot of
opportunities because i lost four state
championships
two all new women awards and countless
other opportunities to play
in advance and medal right so when did
it start that biological boys
trans girls were in the races that you
were in
in girls races yeah my freshman year was
when
it first started happening and and was
it immediate that they were all
like right out of the gate they were
faster and winning all the races
um right off the gate but we're still
placing very high in the state i was
when i was a freshman i placed seventh
at the state open in the hundred meters
and
um one of the biological males was third
knocking me out of the
spot to advance the new england
championship
right so so what caused you to write
this piece and then i'll get to sort of
where the the legal part of this is then
we'll get kristen involved
i really just wanted to bring attention
to what has been happening in
connecticut because
i personally think it's really unfair to
have biological monsters against
biological females because we
just cannot keep up with the physical
advance of a male body
um and so i decided to put out my own
story out there so that people could
understand what was happening and how
unfair it
and to be clear i'm guessing you are not
anti-trans in any way
no no put it out there okay so so
kristin when
did you get involved in all of this
well initially we filed a complaint with
the department of education that was
during the trump administration in june
of 2019
and as time continued to pass and we
weren't seeing
the department of ed take substantive
action on it we ended up filing a
lawsuit
in february of 2020 and that was
chelsea's senior year and
there were some circumstances for her
where she was ready to move forward with
that
and we were glad to assist because there
were four state championship titles that
she
was losing and it was just coming to the
end where we needed to get judicial
relief and so that's why we filed the
lawsuit
right so chelsea what do most people
think
sort of behind the scenes i sense that
there's sort of an activist class and a
a media class that loves pushing these
stories but the average person
that's going to these track events and
watching you lose to a biological male
probably gets why you're upset about
this
yeah i think a lot of um people who have
seen this happen in connecticut
understand how unfair it is basically
because
these biological males were feeding us
females by
significant margins in these races and
it was happening
at every every single race that we raced
against when we were losing and it was
a big difference yeah
so so kristin what what do you want
legally what would be right
for to legally happen at this point
well there are four girls that are in
the case in connecticut two have
graduated and two remain in the
connecticut schools and so for the two
that have graduated including chelsea
and also celina seoul
those records need to be corrected in
this case alone it's important to
realize there were two boys that
identified as girls
one of those boys competed as a girl
three weeks before
he decided to move over and compete as a
girl and those two boys took
15 different races championships away
from girls during those three seasons
so there was a huge impact in
connecticut so we want the records to be
set straight
and then for the girls that are
continuing in this connecticut system
they need to be assured that there are
going to be biological girls competing
against each other
and that it's going to be a fair playing
field moving forward
i suspect i know the answer to this
question but is there any evidence
of biological girls transitioning
to be boys and then winning in boys
sports
i i none that i can think of i mean i'm
sure there may be isolated cases where
that's true but what we do know is that
when boys transition into the girl
sports
there are hundreds literally hundreds of
high school boys that can beat the most
elite female runners and they have a 10
to 50
performance gap so when you're just
looking at averages alone
immediate mediocre male athlete will
almost
always be able to beat an elite female
athlete
now chelsea if i was to repeat what
kristin just said right there somebody
would say you're being transphobic boys
and girls men and women are exactly the
same do you concede that there are some
biological differences of course there
are biological differences
between males and females that's why we
have sex separated sports i mean
uh you know it's kind of hard to just
put the biological male in the you know
category and say that
it's not an issue um when i know how
many boys um in this school could easily
be beaten
um and they would not win the state
championship if they were in the boy
category
right so what would you prefer that that
those trans
athletes do should they have their own
division all together or
you would just prefer that okay you were
born
male you should just be competing with
the with the boys regardless of how you
feel about yourself
something like that i think the most
important thing right now
is to protect the female category and
make sure
that us males are having a fair
competition and i think that should be
the number one priority
right kristen what do you make of uh usa
today switching some of the language
here i mean once you submit an op-ed
you know you know chelsea wrote a piece
that was honest and heartfelt
and then suddenly it's not just that
they're changing language the
implication is somehow
that what chelsea was saying was somehow
hateful
it was shocking to us i mean we we write
op-eds all the time our clients are
writing op-eds
and we can't think of any other instance
in the 30-year history we've been
involved in public interest law
where they have felt like they could
change what someone else wrote without
even
advance notice like we didn't get a call
that said hey just want you to know
this just happened and it's just it's
shocking in terms of the lack of
journalistic integrity
and also the accusations because nothing
could be further from the truth
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about women's
issues instead of non-stop yelling check
out our women's issues playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell